vestigators are trying to determine how
a gas leak triggered a deadly explosion
at a school in Minneapolis the massive
blast yesterday destroyed an entire
section of the school it ripped huge
holes in the sides of buildings the
bodies of receptionist Ruth Berg and
part-time janitor John Carlson were
found in the rubble nine others were
hurt Anna Werner is in Minneapolis near
the private Christian schools campus and
a good morning good morning if you look
at that building behind me you see the
hole to the left of the chimney that's
what the force of this blast did to this
brick school now three people are still
in the hospital one in critical
condition fire officials are reported to
have said that contractors were working
on one of the buildings here at the time
of the blast the careful search through
the rubble in mini haha Academy
stretched on for nearly ten hours late
Wednesday a second victim was pulled
from the blast zone a beloved school
alum and custodian one was lower than
the other deeper in the rubble but
they're both primarily in the same
location John Carlson a retired 82 year
old who did part-time janitor work
leaves behind a wife and children
receptionist Ruth Berg was found earlier
in the day she was a 47 year old mother
of one engaged to be married since it's
summer only a small number of staff
members and students were on campus we
heard a man yell gas and get out this
student saw the blast during soccer
practice I know the man who was standing
in the doorway he he did not make it out
the powerful explosion instantly changed
the face of the century-old private
school heard the blast felt the windows
shake saw that where the building used
to be one continuous building now
a gap the contrast between the
before-and-after is stunning the city's
fire chief said investigators will have
to tread lightly while trying to
pinpoint the cause it's gonna be
precarious for those folks to do their
work in that in that structure and you
can tell they even looks unstable even
looking at it from here classes were
supposed to be back in session here in
20 days that now is in doubt but the
truly fortunate thing here is that
school was not in session or a lot of
students would have been hurt glad and a
thanks